Y
AND FRIGHTENING.
I APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU ARE
DOING IN THIS.
TERRY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO BILL de BLASIO
HAS BEEN OUT OF THE FRONT PAGE
FOR ABOUT FIVE MONTHS, NO LONGER
THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK, HE HAS
NOTHING TO DO, SMOKE A LITTLE
WEED, WATCH A LITTLE NETFLIX, HE
IS BORED, SO HE IS GOING TO RUN
FOR OFFICE AGAIN.
HE IS GOING TO RUN FOR CONGRESS
FROM NEW YORK.
WHAT IS THAT GOING TO LOOK LIKE?
TO MARK THE OCCASION WE WANT TO
RUN THROUGH SOME OF HIS
BIGGEST MOMENTS AS THE MAYOR
OF THE CITY OF NEW YORK, BACK IR
FAVORITE, HE CELEBRATED
GROUNDHOG DAY BY KILLING THE
GROUNDHOG.
>> THIS FOOTAGE FROM
GROUNDHOG DAY 2014 SHOWS FRESHLY
INAUGURATED MAYOR
BILL de BLASIO APPEARING TO
DROP STATEN ISLAND CHUCK.
IT WEEK AFTER THE de BLASIO
FUMBLE, THEY DID A FEW MORE
EVENTS BEFORE BEING FOUND IN A
ZOO SPACE DECEASED ON
FEBRUARY 9TH.
>> Tucker: SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
HE WAS GOING TO DO TO MIDTOWN
WHAT HE DID TO THE GROUNDHOG,
WHICH HE DID, BY 2019, HE BECAMY
DEMENTED AND STARTED TALKING
LIKE A CHIPMUNK.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> TELLING US, DONE ALONG TIME
AGO, PASSING LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR TO GUARANTEE WORKING PEOPLE
LIKE EVERY OTHER INDUSTRIALIZED
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD, GUARANTEE
WORKING PEOPLE BY LAW TWO WEEKS
PAID VACATION EVERY YEAR.
>> Tucker: HE WAS SCRAPING THE
BOND RESIN OUT OF THAT, START
TAKING HITS OFF A HELIUM
BALLOON.
OF ONE OF THE WEIRDEST MOMENTS
OF ALL CAME LAST MAY WHEN HE
ANNOUNCED SHAIKH SHED WOULD GIVE
FREE FOOD TO PEOPLE WHO GOT THE
COVID SHOT BECAUSE I WOULD
EITHER THE PANDEMIC.
>> FREE FRIES WHEN YOU GET
VACCINATED.
I GOT VACCINATED.
YOU ARE SAYING I COULD GET THIS,
THESE DELICIOUS FRIES, JUST
THINK OF THIS WHEN YOU THINK OF
VACCINATION.
MM!
>> Tucker: HE IS SO HIGH.
I MEAN, IT IS JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
THE HOST OF FOX ACROSS AMERICA,S
TONIGHT.
JIMMY, ARE YOU EXCITED FOR THE
RETURN OF THIS MAN?
>> LISTEN, I CAN'T BLAME HIM FOR
TRYING AGAIN.
IT IS HARD TO GET A GIG WHEN THE
ONLY THING BEEN ENDORSED FOR ON
LINKEDIN IS KILLING GROUNDHOGS
AND TRASHING CITIES, DOES NOT
LOOK THE BEST.
I HAVE TO CORRECT YOU -- I HATE
TO BE A FACT-CHECKER, BUT HE DID
NOT KILL THE GROUNDHOG.
WHAT HAPPENED, AFTER BEING SEEN
WITH HIM PUBLICLY, THE GROUNDHOG
DIED OF EMBARRASSMENT.
YOU TOOK A LOOK AT THE POLL
NUMBERS WHEN de BLASIO RAN
FOR PRESIDENT, AND THE CAMPAIGN
DIED QUICKER THAN A CARNIVAL
GOLDFISH BECAUSE OF WHAT HE HAS
DONE TO THE CITY AND I WANT TO
START THERE, OKAY?
NEW YORK CITY AND THE IDEA HE
HAD THE NERVE TO ASK FOR
ANYONE'S VOTE AFTER WHAT HE DID
TO NEW YORK.
NEW YORK CITY RIGHT NOW, TUCKER,
LOOKS LIKE GOTHAM BEFORE BATMAN
COMES EXCEPT BATMAN IS NOT
COMING BECAUSE HE IS NOT
VACCINATED.
HE AIN'T SHOWING UP.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO BACK TO WAYNE
MANOR, I'M SORRY, 6 FEET OF
SPACE, WE WILL FIGHT THE CRIME
VIRTUALLY.
AND THAT IS THE ISSUE.
MY FAMILY WAS GOING TO COME TO
NEW YORK CITY THIS WEEKEND BUT
THEY DECIDED TO GO SOMEPLACE
SAFER LIKE BEIRUT BECAUSE THE
IDIOTS WHO RAN THE CITY INTO THE
GROUND WAS ALWAYS GOING FOR
THE PERFORMATIVE STUPIDITY,
CREATING THE APPEARANCE THAT HE
CARED AND HE WAS DOING
SOMETHING.
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT WAS THAT
VACCINE VIDEO WHERE HE IS
STUFFING HIS FACE WITH
FRENCH FRIES.
HEY, TUCKER, WHAT IS THE LEADING
KILLER FROM COVID?
OBESITY.
SO WE ARE COMBATING VACCINE
HESITANCY BY ENCOURAGING FRIED
FOOD CONSUMPTION?
THIS IS LIKE COMBATING ARSON BY
GIVING AWAY BOOK OF MATCHES,
MAN.
THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY TO
THAT AS MAY BE THE UPSIDE TO THE
BIDEN PRESIDENCY IS ARSON IS
DOWN BECAUSE NO ONE CAN BURN
DOWN YOUR HOUSE AT $5.15 A
GALLON, THEY HAVE TO REALLY LOVE
YOU TO DO IT.
AS FAR AS de BLASIO GOES,
HILARIOUS, HE IMPLEMENT A
VACCINE MANDATE IN TIMES SQUARE
ON NEW YEAR'S EVE, MAN, ON
NEW YEAR'S EVE.
TUCKER COME IF YOU ARE PARTYING
IN TIMES SQUARE ON
NEW YEAR'S EVE, COVID IS NOT A
TOP TEN GERM YOU ARE WEIRD ABOUT
CATCHING.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY RELIEVED
WHEN -- OKAY?
THAT IS NEW YORK IN A NUTSHELL.
FOR THE MIDWEST, NEW YORK AND
MOST BLUE CITIES ARE RUN BY
STUPID PEOPLE WHO THINK THEY ARE
SMARTER THAN YOU, WHICH IS WHY
RIGHT NOW WITH OUR SUBWAY IN THE
CONDITION IT IS IN, TUCKER, WE
JUST OPENED UP A $30 MILLION
STAIRCASE ON THE NEW YORK CITY
SUBWAY, AND I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE WATCHING ARE LIKE, WOW,
JIMMY, TUCKER, $30 MILLION IS A
LOT FOR A STAIRCASE, BUT I
SHOULD REMIND YOU IT ALSO
DOUBLES AS A RESTROOM AND A
PLACE TO SHOOT HEROIN, SO YOU
ARE GETTING LIKE A THREE FORMAT
ONE DEAL HERE, AND THAT IS WHY
IT IS SO DISGUSTING.
THE CITY'S GROSS, OKAY, AND IF
YOU REALLY CARED ABOUT IT, YOU
DO NOT BUILD A STAIRWAY INTO THE
SUBWAY, YOU ACTUALLY CLEAN UP
THE SUBWAY, TUCKER, HAVE YOU
EVER RIDDEN THE ONE TRAIN AND
NOT SEEN SOMEONE FONDLING
THEMSELVES?
EVERY TIME I SWIPE MY CARD I
FEEL LIKE I'M ENTERING THE ZOOM
WITH JEFFREY TOOBIN, COME ON,
MAN